So that's at least in a nut shell the reinforcement learning story.
There's there's a lot of other topics and I think we are
planning to get to some of them in a topics lesson a
little bit later, but there's you know, courses and books worth of stuff
to study in this area. Just like supervised learning as a whole.
But, we're going to just kind of end it there with the idea
that we now have a handle on how we can use learning
to do decisions with delayed rewards. So, can you help us summarize what
we what we learned in this lesson?
>> Okay, sure. I think what did I learn here today,
I think I learned a lot of things, some of which had
to do with reinforcement learning Mainly that you can actually learn how
to solve an MDP. I think that's actually a pretty big deal.
>> Right. Meaning that we don't know T and R.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But we just have access to. The
ability to interact with the environment and recieve transitions.
>> And, that's actually that's actually pretty
impressive. And, a very powerful thing. Because,
we're often not, if we assume the world is an MDP, but we don't know
TNR. If we don't have some way of learning in that we don't really have
much we can do. And, you've showed me that their is something we can do.
>> Cool.
>> I think that's the biggest thing. We learned
some specific things. In particular, we learned about Q-learning.
>> Several kinds of Q-learning, but one is actually a real word.
>> Yes [LAUGH]
indeed they're all real, Michael. We learned about Q-learning. And I think the
other most important thing that we learned
about is the exploration versus exploitation trail.
>> And with Q-learning, we learned a little bit about when it converges.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that it's actually a family of
algorithms. And different members of that family have different
behaviors associated with them. Oh, there's one other
thing I wanted to say on that topic, actually.
>> Okay. Which is, that one way to
achieve this exploration-exploitation balance, was to
randomly choose actions. So to change
the we're doing action selection. But there's another one too, which is that
we can actually by manipulating the initialization of the Q function. We can
actually get another kind of exploration, can you see how that might work?
>> Oh, I know what you do. If you could, if
you set, say the Q values to all be the highest
possible value they could be.
>> Great, so if we initialized the Q hat to awesome values, then what the
Q lettering algorithm would do, even with
greedy exploration, what it will do is it
will try things that it hasn't tried very much, and it still thinks are awesome.
And little by little, it gets a more
realistic sense of how the environment works. And.
>> So it's very optimistic?
>> That's right, exactly and it's referred to often as optimism in
the face of uncertainty and it's a similar kind of idea that's
used in algorithms like, A*, if you're familiar with search algorithms in AI.
>> Oh yes, I remember those.
>> But this is, this is a really powerful idea and it's
used in, in reinforcement learning and
banded algorithms and planning and And search.
>> Okay, and that makes sense because if
everything is awesome. Then your true key value
can only go down if awesome is bigger
than the biggest Q value you could ever have.
And so that means you're going to look at every single action. And as you learn
more about them, then you will just
get more depressed about them. And that's good.
>> [LAUGH] Yes the world slowly beats you
down. [LAUGH] So is that it? Is that all
we really talked about? I guess that's about
right. We talked about what a que function was.
>> Right.
>> And how that kind of binds everything together
and we talked about different approaches including policy search and
model base reinforcement learning.
>> Yeah that was very nice. We tied it all back into planning.
>> So one, one thing we didn't talk about
is connecting to function approximation, and the issues in
machine learning that are really important things things like
over fitting. They come up in the reinforcement learning setting,
but not in this simplified setting that were looking
at here where we learn a separate value. For
each state action pair, we're going to have to
start generalizing to see the importance of that. And that's,
we're going to do in a later lesson.
>> Okay. I like it. And we also learned
a bunch of things about letters. Like exploration versus exploitation.
>> In fact, we know enough that we can now get an A in letters.
>> [LAUGH]
I like it. Okay. Well, I think we learned a lot, Michael.
>> [LAUGH] Okay. Well, good. Well, thanks. It's very nice
to get a chance to talk to you about this stuff.
>> Cool. And so I guess. What are we going to talk about next.
>> Well Whatever it says on the syllabus.
>> I think it's game theory.
>> That's pretty cool.
>> Oh. I see why we're going to do that.
Because all we've been talking about the world as if
there were just one agent and nobody else. And now
we're going to see what happens. When there are other people.
>> Right. Other people show up at the party, next time.
>> On, Machine Learning.